how can a guy balance saving money but
also
you know land a hot chick like you guys
i don't like to know that a guy is
saving money i like to know that a guy
is investing his money and that he can
give me the right advice hey
put 20 000 here thirty thousand dollars
here and see what happens when i hear a
guy saving money i'm like
what you know i want a man that that
will teach me about money and and
you know and real estate and you know
somebody who can educate me on wealth
creation gotcha so it's more attractive
when they stimulate your brain on
investing
than okay tidbits on saving money but um
i'm not trying to date a couponer
and i don't like to hear a man saying oh
i'm saving money for this that's a turn
off to me really how do you mean
i don't know it's just like i want a man
with that mindset that's it's so big
that it's not about saving it like he's
looking to create wealth
right and he already has systems and in
place to make that happen in 10 15 years
from now you know this is what i'm
looking i'm aiming for okay and if a guy
is struggling
but he's ambitious
what are some
words or phrases he can say that aren't
gonna turn you off meaning let's say he
is
paycheck to paycheck right now let's say
he is struggling with infection rents
you know he's
times are tough
what can he say
that you won't be like oh this guy's
broke say nothing
no say nothing say nothing yeah
say nothing because a woman doesn't need
to know
uh what does turn me on is to see a man
that's really really working on himself
on his mindset that has a business coach
that's going to events that are going to
elevate his business his mind his life
right someone who's consistently uh
surrounding himself with amazing
people and pouring into himself and also
into other people yeah i see those same
guys who are like you know struggling
but trying to be driven going to the
clubs on the weekend
you see them spending their money
elsewhere you don't see them investing
in themselves well one of the things i
always say about money
uh and money management is that 50 of it
is knowledge and understanding what to
do and the other 50 is behavior and your
actions and are your actions aligned
with your knowledge like you know
that you're trying to save money but you
all up in the club dog
right you know that you're trying to
lose weight
but you're ordering large fries with jp
over here
so your actions aren't exactly aligned
with uh you know it's like
don't talk to talk walk the walk right
uh you want to weigh in on this sir yeah
i think that if someone says i'm saving
money for something that's for them to
spend it on something that's not going
to have them grow which is why i totally
agree with that when i hear someone's
like oh i'm saving money to go to this
concert i'm like
that's just a temporary thing you're not
looking at the bigger picture same with
i agree with penny pension i think
couponing and all this stuff they're not
looking at the bigger picture yeah with
you doing all this stuff if you just
focus your energy on on on scaling what
you're doing then none of that stuff
matters anymore it just becomes like
negligible on the grand scheme what's
the phrase don't walk over dollars to
pick up pennies yeah my phrases go big
or go home so okay you ain't going big
just go home hey player go big or go
home sometimes uh when i hear my friend
say oh i had to move out of my apartment
because i couldn't afford this or i
can't afford this or i can't go to this
restaurant because i can't afford it for
me the way i think about it what do i
have to start implementing into my life
so i can afford it so i don't need to
move out of my apartment if the rent
went up a thousand dollars you know so
what are you know what do i need to do
in my business in order to make that
extra 10 15. yeah well one of the things
i always say you know a budget or a
financial game plan is uh your income
minus your expenses
so i equate it to i'm a big sports guy
offense and defense your income is your
offense
right putting points up on the board
we're scoring we're doing it we're
making money
defense is limiting your expenses right
it's how much is rent how much is car
payments how much is gas you know every
food a cell phone like so you have to be
like the best team
isn't necessarily the team that has the
best offense and the best team isn't
necessarily the team that has the best
defense it's the team that has the best
of both
like let's use a football analogy
there's 32 football teams you might be
number
you know
five on offense but you're number 12 on
defense and like all right cool that's
good but you might be number one on
offense but if you're like number 28 on
defense it's it's not going to work you
see what i'm saying so do the same thing
with your with your with your budget
um like my defense is
bananas right i'm good like i don't
spend my i have a sick apartment that's
what i spend my money on and all i do is
focus on offense
to make more money make more money
because my i have a solid defense anyway
little tidbit out there understand the
difference between offense and defense
so if you like that clip click right
here to watch another or if you want to
watch the entire sauce cast click right
here
[Music]